it's pretty crazy stuff she started it
and it's time for her to finish it you
kidding me the last 10 years were
chock-full of celebrity clap backs shade
and downright pettiness you never really
good off we've never been friends
now et is breaking down the 7 biggest
feuds of the 2010s
starting with Justin Bieber and Orlando
Bloom it all went down in 2012 when
Justin performed at the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show at the time
Justin was dating Selena Gomez and
Miranda Kerr was married to Orlando but
according to reports justin was seen
giving Miranda a kiss on the cheek at
the after-party fitting room days later
et confirmed his breakup with Selena and
in 2013 Miranda and Orlando called it
quits fast forward to 2014 a report
claimed Orlando took a swing at Justin
at a restaurant in Ibiza it's pretty
crazy stuff shortly after the alleged
altercation
Justin posted a pic of Miranda on
Instagram with a crown emoji in the
caption only to delete the pic just
minutes later something else oh and
let's not forget Orlando was spotted
hanging out with Selena in 2014 and then
again in 2016 so there's that next up
Taylor Swift vs. Katy Perry
[Music]
[Applause]
in 2014 Taylor reveals her hit bad blood
was inspired by a fellow pop star
telling Rolling Stone quote she did
something so horrible I was like oh
we're just straight-up enemies
she basically tried to sabotage an
entire arena tour she tried to hire a
bunch of people out from under me well
fans did some digging and pointed out
that Katie had hired a few backup
dancers from Taylor's tour for her own
prismatic tour in 2014 it was a full
shutdown in this she writes a song about
me and I'm like okay cool cool cool
that's how you want to do with it karma
following Taylor's interview Katy
tweeted watch out for the Regina George
in sheep's clothing and in 2015 told
Billboard magazine quote if somebody is
trying to defame my character you're
going to hear about it honestly it's
really like she started it and it's time
for her to finish it I'm ready for that
BS to be done now there is the law of
cause and effect you do something and
there's gonna be a reaction and trust me
daddy there's gonna be a reaction Taylor
stayed mom about all that but in 2017
she announced that her entire song
catalog would return to streaming
services the same day Katy's album
witness dropped but by spring 2018 the
two settled their differences Katie sent
Taylor a peace offering so I just got to
my dressing room and found this actual
Olive Branch this means so much to me
Taylor made Katie some cookies and the
two hugged it out in Taylors you need to
calm down video
what about the rumors that Katy Perry
and Taylor Swift could make music
together I'm open open open open number
five
Gwyneth Paltrow versus Martha Stewart
she really wants to be part of the
lifestyle business she wants to be a
lifestyle arbiter fine good I'm I think
I started this whole category of
lifestyle that was Martha talking about
the GUP founder in 2013 one year later
Gweneth company hired Martha Stewart
Living CEO Lisa Gersh
that's when Martha told Neda Portier
magazine quote she just needs to be
quiet she's a movie star if she were
confident in her acting she wouldn't be
trying to be Martha Stewart what's your
reaction to that first of all no one has
ever said anything bad about me before
shocked and devastated try to recover
and then the lifestyle guru not so
subtly dissed Gwyneth's famous conscious
uncoupling in the November 2014 issue of
Martha Stewart living with a spread
titled conscious coupling offering
suggestions for the perfect marriage of
crusts and filling combinations but
Gweneth had the last laugh sharing a
recipe on her site for jailbird cake
which was seemingly a dig at the five
months Martha spent behind bars in 2004
on fraud charges next up Kim Cattrall
vs. Sarah Jessica Parker for years
rumors circulated that there was beef
between the Sex and the City co-stars
this sort of narrative this ongoing
catfight it really used to be really
really not even earth it really upset me
then in 2017
SJP confirmed they weren't making a
third sex in the city film and reports
surfaced that Kim was to blame that I'm
demanding more in diva and and this is
this is really where I I take to task
the people from Sex in the City and
specifically Sarah Jessica Parker is
that I think she could have been nicer I
really think she could have been nicer
I found it very upsetting because that's
you know that's not the way I recall our
experience so it's sad in February 2018
Kim announced that her brother had died
unexpectedly and Sarah Jessica commented
on her former co-stars Instagram sending
love and condolences somebody in your
life whether you're in touch with them
all the time or not and they are
suffering for any reason it's
involuntary that you want to convey
condolences or sadness or just let
someone know that you're thinking about
them that's when Kim posted this
scathing message calling Sarah Jessica a
hypocrite and cruel in the caption quote
let me make this very clear you are not
my family you are not my friend stop
exploiting our tragedy in order to
restore your nice girl persona and who
could forget the epic Smackdown that was
Drake versus Pusha T push a drop the mic
in 2018 when he exposed that Drake had a
secret love child Beyonce in the now
legendary diss track the story of ad
anon he raps about how Drake had a kid
with former adult film star Sophie
Brazeau a baby's involved is deeper than
rap we talking character let me keep
with the facts
you are hiding a child that that boy
come home
deadbeat mother playing Border Patrol
Drake later acknowledged he had a son in
his 2018 album scorpion that wasn't hot
in my kid from the world I was my kid he
also addressed the scandal on LeBron
James's show the shop I knew something
was gonna come up about my kid they had
to add like the deadbeat thing to make
it more appealing which is fine I
understand that and he said he thought
Kanye West was the one who told Pusha
about his son I'm in Wyoming I play a
March 14th I sent him a picture of my
son oh my god I tell him I'm having
trouble with my son's mother we had a
conversation number two on our list Kim
Kardashian versus Chloe grace Moretz the
beef kicked off in March 2016
when Kim posted this naked selfie to
Instagram I'm never not proud of
anything that I have shared Chloe
weighed in on Twitter urging Kim to
teach girls that they have so much more
to offer than just their bodies that's
when Kim hit back tweeting let's all
welcome at Khloe G Moretz to Twitter
since no one knows who she is I love
that and that's what we call a clap back
folks a few months later the feud heated
up again when Khloe came out as a member
of Team Taylor following Kanye West's
now-infamous track famous that know me
best I feel like me and Taylor might
still have sex why I made famous I made
famous and Kim snapchats about it Khloe
tweeted everyone in this industry needs
to get their heads out of their a hole
and look around to realize what's
actually happening in the real world
stop wasting your voice on something so
petulant and unimportant I could care
less what anyone thinks or says that's
when Kim's little sis Chloe chimed in
sharing a paparazzi photo of a mystery
blonde that kind of resembled Chloe
wearing an itty-bitty barely-there
bikini over her but she wrote is this
the a-hole you're referring to at Chloe
G Moretz Chloe later hit Chloe with a
fact check tweeting that the pic in
question was in fact not of her and last
but not least Joy Behar versus Megan
McCain the women of the view are no
stranger to a heated debate
I think that's why people like the show
and in 2019 the ladies got into an
intense discussion about president
Trump's supporters sometimes it's not
just that they love Trump so much it's
that they hate the same things Trump
hates that's what's going mean and I am
it who does a hey things went from bad
to worse you know what joy I really love
their everyday open-minded just trying
to explain it okay not a fun job but
everybody hate I know you're angry
you're angry that Trump's president like
a lot of Clement that every single
Dino's doing yelling at me is gonna fix
the problem then Megan hit joy with this
choice five letter word
Republican every day well but all's well
that ends well what is the one thing you
want the public to know about our
relationship that we like each other
they keep writing things about how we
can't stand each other it's really hurts
my feelings